les chéris vrai ou faux le clip de pukki
et la vidéo la plus regardée de l'année
sur youtube en france en 2019
vrai ou faux le clip de pukki diana
camorra vrai ou faux vrai vrai vrai vrai
vous dites faut les deux est-ce que
c'est faux kelly kelly c'est vrai c'est
vrai
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête de ma mère c'est vrai mais
pourquoi mathieu et j'espère que c'est
faux j'suis pas fan diana cannois dont
j'espère que les gens un peu mou et bien
c'est vrai elle a été vue 149 millions
de fois choisi son nom de scène en
référence à un personnage japonais de
série et surtout à diana qu'à moi elle
était dans une séquence qui a fait
énormément c'est c'est voila ca ya
nakamura qui va un peu paniqué au moment
où nagui une demande de lancer un appel
aux dons qui du tournoi et rac
oui c'est d'intimider le monde en a
parlé ça veut dire choquée sur plaidé
devant le soul est là alors regardez
message que vous pourriez peut-être
passé à ceux qui vous aiment et qui vous
suivent au 36 37 merci aujourd'hui de
m'accompagner de me soutenir de
m'encourager dans ce que je fais c'est
super important vous ne voyez pas
forcément tous les jours mais ça me ça
me booste
voilà merci encore et pour le téléthon
si vous avez message à passer à vos fans
pour qu'ils soutiennent le téléthon
byetta appeler le 36 37 pour aider la
recherche est stoppée stopper non il
faut arrêter les maladies elle est bien
d'aider les gens voilà donc je vous
invite à après 6,37 merci beaucoup n'y a
qu'un
nakamura
[Applaudissements]
on va pas la tête alors c'est vrai que
sur twitter ça fait c'est un déferlement
il ya guy carlier qui n'a pas épargné la
chanteuse jeane yanagi dans sa façon de
contenir son indignation et de dire
d'une fois terriblement ironique et
sinon pour le téléthon un mot après que
cette dame tellement vulgaire et
arriviste et fait sa promo éhontée
tandis qu'on voyait en plans de coupe
les petits myopathe alors qu'est ce que
vous en pensez chez que tu en as voilà
qui ont défendu la star également voilà
je pense qu'elle n'a pas bien compris la
question il ya des gens qui disent ça
parce qu'elle a peut-être pas bien
entendu qui dit moi je trouve que c'est
clairement de l'acharnement parce que
quand on la connaît un petit peu elle
est timide c'est aussi une artiste qui
se produit devant des milliers de
personnes que le malaise bah oui on la
connaît comment est ce qu'elle est et
nagui j'ai pas trop aimé non plus
comment il a été parce que quand on a
des invités et qu'on les apprécie et
qu'on les invite à un moment donné on
les aide un petit peu quand on voit
qu'ils sont un petit peu en galère mais
c'était un petit peu après la terre j'ai
appris il apprit à jouer après la pensée
au téléthon a dit oui mais j'ai dû dire
du désert utc pas l'émission d'alertés
sera que de leur beau nom mais je veux
dire voilà moi j'ai trop bu voilà j'ai
juste à moosch voilà je pense que le
vernis craque on a vu la vraie
personnalité de la de la jeune fille je
pense pas qu'elles aient paniqué du tout
oui effectivement elle parle d'elle tout
tourne autour d'elle je ne pars la
fraiseraie que que voilà que michel de
kerk avait dit un jour ce qui fait une
carrière c'est la générosité
bon ben voila je lui souhaite d'en avoir
un jour khalid amayreh soient payés oui
non mais après on connaît le peloton
d'exécution des réseaux sociaux ont
effectivement là elle et elle elle est
catastrophique
elle est maladroite et ce qui est gênant
surtout c'est qu'elle a un côté un peu
quand même
warrior femmes fortes donneuse de leçon
on se souvient avec nikos et là
effectivement elle fait petite femme
apeurée complètement perdu et je trouve
que ce qui manque surtout de sa part
c'est un peu d'humilité
un peu d'humour un peu de sourire en or
mais c'est vrai j'ai enfin je trouve
qu'elle est complètement premier degré
et du alors on laisse quelques instants
plus tard elle a tenté de se rattraper
elle a fait une vidéo pour les réseaux
cette fois elle passe un appel aux dons
bengale salut
moi alors je vous invite à aller sur
telethon.fr pour pouvoir faire des dons
pour les enfants malades pour la
recherche c'est important pour les voilà
bon voilà donc ayana qu'à moi c'est vrai
que ça fait énormément parler très
grosse polémique
c'est vrai que ça prend des ampleurs
incroyable sur les réseaux à chaque fois
je me connais ça c'est un message tourne
à droite on en est longue à nikos quand
c'est le connaissons et remettre la
droite revenue n'est pas la hauteur de
2002 c'est son métier et elle en fait
elle est là pour chanter elle n'est pas
là pour s'exprimer les sonos leur
étaient là pour que les fans de voir la
vidéo après c'est un agent qui lui a dit
voir dans ses yeux qu'il allait souffler
au col des malades su